Daniel Radcliffe who played Harry Potter
and is an actor Daniel Radcliffe just
just published some kind of series some
kind of podcast series because every
single white Millennial on planet Earth
I think by federal statute now must have
a podcast Daniel Radcliffe posted this
this long interview in which he is
talking to transgender identifying
people in which he makes a strange Claim
about pedagogy education and the
rational faculties of children
I learned from you know
cradle that I am you know that I was a
boy I should like blue I should like
sports I should be manly I should like
superheroes yeah and I just I never
associate myself with those things and
we are told that we're not old enough to
know to know this yet like I mean I'm
only 11 years old how do I know I'm a
girl and I need more time to think about
this but there are also people who do
have like a slightly condescending but
well-meaning attitude of like well
people are young and like how do we you
know there is a huge decision I'd love
to hear from all of you about like why
we can trust kids to like tell us who
they are I don't understand why I can't
just decide that I'm a girl I if it's a
big decision to decide I'm a girl it's a
big decision to decide I'm a boy right
it's a big big decision to decide to get
a tattoo you're not allowed to do that
it's a big decision to decide to start
smoking cigarettes you're not allowed to
do that you you will be allowed to do
that eventually once you've reached an
age of maturity and reason and consent
when you're 18 and now we keep raising
that you're not you're not allowed in
the United States to to purchase a pack
of cigarettes until you're 21 years old
but you can decide to start the process
that will culminate in you chopping off
your genitals at age eight you can start
the pro frankly even earlier in in
certain locales you can start the
process
that will see you put on puberty
blocking drugs that will see you pumped
full of cross-sex hormones that will see
your body mutilated that will see you
sterilized castrated you can start that
when you're in elementary school
but you can't get a tattoo until you're
18.
you can't buy a drink or smoke a
cigarette until you're 21 does that make
a lot of sense well no because kids kids
don't know if they want to have a tiny
little Japanese character symbol in
green on their wrist like every white
girl in the United States they can't
decide that until they turn 18 but they
can decide to lot their breasts off when
they turn eight right does that make a
lot of sense doesn't make sense to me
keep going inside I'm a boy right it's
just it's the same thing there's no
there's no age you don't have to be 18
to decide that oh I am who I am
okay there it is
both of my examples were sort of harsh
on white people but I think it's they're
especially a little harsh on white
people here because it it appears to me
that it is white liberals in particular
who are so taken with these insane
ideologies it's people like Daniel
Radcliffe
it's people like Robin D'Angelo it's
people like
Randy Weingarten it's people like it's
all it this pathology seems to be
seeping from
very liberal whites I don't know why
that is but it is going out everywhere
to every racial group of people and do
every geography it is actually you know
Emmanuel macron the leader of France was
asked about wokeness
and he said oh that's an American thing
this is the leader of France France is a
very liberal country they said this
wokeness stuff this extreme of
liberalism this extreme of Liberation
that attempts to liberate you even from
your own body even from your own self
that's an American thing we don't do
that here this extreme of Liberation
that says that you don't even need to
cultivate your higher rational will
in order to make these sorts of
decisions you can do it when you're 11.
you can do it from the moment you crawl
out of that crib you can decide that you
are not really yourself and you can
decide to kill your former self and
become a totally new person
but of course that's not the case the
Liberals trying to trans the kids
highlights perfectly something that I
have been
pointing out about Liberty for a long
time which is that
Liberty is a confounding thing because
Liberty and licentiousness are different
things
because Liberty is not merely about what
you will to do because we have two Wills
we have a lower will which is the
appetite and we have a higher will which
is the rational will
and the process of education is about
cultivating the rational will so you can
suppress your appetites and kids by
definition can't do that
that's why if you leave a kid in a room
with a cookie jar the kid is going to
eat all the cookies an adult might eat
all the cookies increasingly in our
undisciplined and decadent Society they
will eat all the cookies but the the
adults have a better chance having
cultivated that rational will having
suppressed those appetites Having
learned to master a little bit their
concupiscence they will be more likely
to discipline themselves
so The Liberation that is offered by the
Liberals is not true Liberty it's not
the Liberty to chart your own course and
pursue the good and and behave in a way
that is rational and conducive to your
human flourishing it's that false kind
of Liberty of eating all the cookies in
the cookie jar or doing a bunch of drugs
or harming yourself it's that false
Liberty
that says that if it feels good do it
but that kind of Liberty is nothing but
slavery that kind of Liberty Liberty
will lead to nothing but your own
destruction it's the liberty of the
heroin addict who's going to be the
freest man in the world until he
overdoses or dies of exposure on the
Streets of San Francisco
it's that it's called licentiousness
that way it lies
destruction
this is what students are being taught
though there's a teacher who just went
viral on Tick Tock who who was boasting
that he passes out chest binders to his
students I teach in an explicitly trans
affirming high school
we have gender support plans we have a
gender affirming wardrobe at our school
we have binders on demand for our
students and other shapewear can easily
be ordered we have students that Express
themselves in all manner of different
ways and I couldn't be prouder to work
at a school that's so amazing if you
would like to have your school also be
explicitly trans affirming school let me
know maybe we can figure something out
have you ever
seen a creepier guy in your whole life
than the kind of guy who seeks out
and explicitly trans affirming High
School
and passes out all sorts of weird sexual
toys to children
and then goes on the internet and
advertises and say hey kids hey hey kids
if you're out there and you want to talk
about weird sex stuff to some adults in
school just give me a shoot me a DM I
love it this is I got the greatest job
in the world I bet you think you do
I bet you think you do man but this this
is the sort of thing that we should not
be tolerating
you're not allowed to teach the Bible in
schools
you're not allowed
to pray to God in schools
it is increasingly Politically Incorrect
to say the Pledge of Allegiance in
schools
but now we have trans affirming schools
in which teachers pass out sex toys
to children
we're going to have some standards
the people who oppose the Bible in
schools
that the ones who did so with good
intentions like like the pavement to the
road of hell some people have good
intentions they said well we don't want
to force any religious beliefs on
anybody
so we're just going to get the Bible out
of schools oh we don't want to force
religious beliefs we're going to get
prayer out of schools we don't want to
force patriotic beliefs we're going to
get the Pledge of Allegiance out of
schools
they did so in in the according to the
false perception
false conception that
we would then have a neutral School
you can't have a neutral school you
can't have a neutral Society but you
certainly can't have a neutral School
via schools teach things
so when you take one idea out of a
school
it creates a vacuum something else will
fill that vacuum you take the American
flag out of the classroom the pride flag
will fill that you take God out of the
classroom some Idol will fill that you
take Christianity out of the classroom
which says that man is a compositive
body and soul and the soul is a
substantial form of the body well
transgenderism is going to fill that
vacuum which says that man is is a
duality between body and soul and your
soul and your body don't have any real
relation to one another they can be in
opposition and if you if you feel any
discomfort about your physical self well
you should hate your physical self
that's not really you chop it up
sterilize it
that's what's going that's what's always
going to fill it and so
we have to have a clear vision of not
just
how we want children to develop critical
thinking skills but we have to first
answer what should they think you can't
learn how to think before you learn what
to think at least about certain basic
things we got a guy on
friend of mine who wants to have the top
job in the country
that would be my friend Vivek ramaswami
so get your questions for Vivek in
we will be Fielding your questions
for the vague coming up here on the
member block the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
go to dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles Canada wlas a check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh
foreign